hello hello Graham how are you I'm very
well what's your name sir God Hodges
Scott okay and that where are you Scott
I'm in Salt Lake City Utah Salt Lake
City well thank you for joining us and
going to all out with the red red
t-shirt red chair the works a normally
do in Salt Lake City I'm actually a
manager for a company and I oversee some
installers in Texas Oklahoma and Kansas
and make sure they install our
telephones the correct way okay off we
go with this story okay very good
several years ago I lived in Southern
California and I worked at a bank and I
was bank teller and my the teller next
to me and I could tell we were getting
robbed by two gentlemen coming up to us
and we were waiting for it and I asked
him can I help you
and the guy slammed a note down in front
of me and said this is a robbery give me
all the money in the cash register in
the in the drawers and so we did what
they told and we threw our money into
their bags their act and they took off
and headed out the door they even said
have a nice day
and they headed out the door and I we
called the detectives and gave
descriptions of them and everything and
my adrenaline started coming back down
and I was like I'm gonna pass out I need
to go sit down my manager said go sit in
the lobby real quick on the comfy chairs
and relax so I went out there and I'm
sitting down for about a couple seconds
and I look over at my teller window and
I see something sitting there I'm like
what is that and so I go walking over to
it and I reach down and I picked up my
robbers wallet he had actually left his
wallet on the counter and I looked at
him yep that's him and when the
detectives came to interview me and they
said can you describe but I said yep he
looks like that Wow that story is too
good for this show
true story there's a Netflix documentary
series in oz you can walk thank you
never know quality like it done
[Music]